これじゃあ&板長とこんちゃーたマッチですはいたランチさんはい
あなたはつい最近まで学生さんですよねはいどうでしたか
学生生活だ
いやまぁ他の鮮魚せなかったですよねー
メキシコはしなかったですねこの抉らネルギー
グサッいる小畑夏のことどうこう言えるわけでありません学生というものを離れて2年
以上が経っております方向つやろでございますまあ2年以上ねばから動画を作ることに
専念しているとさすがに僕ももうないの芯からアホになってしまっている
そして彼もまた
言われたてからのシンガーボーン
いいすぎ列車親亡きますや賢いできてああああすごいんですけど勉強って概念において
まーすとた夏とお礼がちょっと深くていいかないバカなんじゃないかこっから皆さん
想像する以上にはだからバカ年生が我々は舐めるじゃあ行かんとカメラで真っ赤じゃ
ダメだということで今回はこちら
2018年度の東大の前キロ入学試験問題を選んだ国準備しました今年の春にあった
問題の前戯の入学試験問題の国語数学理科社会を持っていました英語が調べたんです
けど非公開に食べたみたい伍佰手に入ったのが国語数学理科社会
4つでございます東大ってことは度これが
あの日本で一番難しい入学試験問題だと思うんですよ
普通に考えてまだ2人が力を合わせれば東西の入試問題だろうが俺だよって書かれば
東大がどれだけこのためちゃ耐えれるか
ああ
本当にちょっと原画にコカインでみたいと思っておりますたまに勉強しなくなります
たまに勉強してください金を特に僕は全会計の欲が強くて
通例といっしょしながら漸化式を作ろうと思い考えておりますぜひありますか
ブーバースイーツアルファーヘッドと数字を一緒にするんじゃないイカロス地獄が朝の
もうすごい
tetsuya 上等フラフラなんですけどもグラグラの墓負担をあわせても東大に
どれか迎えるかというの方がちょっと実験的にやってみようと思いまー
ちょっと気持ちは暑いかもしれませんが聞いてついてました代打小窪ですこれやべーぞ
体やうわーん
まああれだよん
人たちからあれだんっ
ヤバイ奴がそれを築いたん
センター試験はマーク好きなんだけど二次試験だから書かせるのが重い
まじ系あたんねーすでそれちょっとれたニュアンスがあっていればます一緒になって
この女ってし感じでまずは国語から行けますでは
search 量子力学を基板とそれ現代の物理学理論に他なりません
とはどういうことが説明て行った
4日意味あったらだけですこれこれ笑うだね奴なんだぞ
いう数えろまず俺たちがやらなきゃいけないのはそれにおいて正両親力逆光を基盤と
する現代の物理学理論に他になりません
とはどういうことかを吸っていると思いまーここの棒線部分ですよねどういうことにょ
まあその何か器具です
そのは多分ミクロな粒子の運動のマクロのコーン的なことなんだ
の枕花本籍がその痕跡です荷電粒子が通過してきた
三井できゃーわー女性であることを保証しているのは
量子力学を基盤とする経済の物理学議論に他なりません
どういうこと思っ
拳を固め1解けないとに解けないっスよねもよくでるんだ
各国語版上書くだけでいいんだよほんとだつまり俺たちはまず覚悟で無理やしつまぐん
いいところ床を跳ぼうとするって言う4時間がかかったね論文の問題って基本的に
漢字を答えさせる問題があるんでフッ
はい普通にずれ書だからつ粒子のような理由を持って進んだ前日へせよ
g 1ございますね
展示取材落とし込みでね
黒とローンを外れつする
待ってやばいサイクロ本だってやばいよ
言葉がわからない前にフランスかけメイト明治維新で具体的に何かあったかと言われる
といろんなことがあってそれを引っかかれた実証なんだよと抽象的な会員
すぎ心からになっちゃっててそのまま成長しちゃって
ゴミ人間になってしまいます
多分なかなか返事が来なくてって事はそういう事ですね
うちも置かれずおおー
これを見てこの人が
古代の王のこと話です古代のてよがプラン開始の弱そうそうそうですね
[音楽]
国語線量ですごいここ40分で終わらせてるじゃないですか
タイム的には悪くないですね続いてすごく行きます
開始1敗
座標平面上に放物線 c をは=は混沌所 x =2
3+ね doobie の著名な新聞紙へすげー
そんな感じだった記憶はありますけどあってる時セラー2歩目プライズ
無理だな時に問題を解くのが5ですからね東大はいやーなんか懐かしいや実数解って
いう言葉はわかるんだけど
単調に増加するためにええについての条件端緒に増加するっていう今単語の意味が
わからないんです
強く割合やちょっと立系
なんですけど悔しいことにも何一つ分かりませんでしたすごいでも11分で終わりまし
た
台風はまま台湾いいですかまぁ3時間目社会ですはい回収
日本史が何も店にゲームあっ
上がって俺だってさっき俺が言ってたのを聞きましたん
ちょっと前世平安時代付けなんですよ
俺
時代俺の前世より前の話ですからねこれなんか大きい平安京だもんね
ちょっと雑感多いのが早いのかなくと大花柄状況です
平蔵強化
いやなんかバック的な話だってのがまっすぐ上なんと借金的なのも全部帳消しにする
よって行ったせいで動いて広域的なと闘志に入ってるんだけどもそれをなんか
3つえーしてやってるから
2両通常社会終了
社会やってみて思ったのは何か参考資料はたくさんあるんですけど根本的な中知識が
ないと解けない問題だらけで色々考えてみ
ミッターもののちょっとよくわかんなかったですね持ってかれましたね
ブーブーに疲れパパでも全力出したと思うんじゃより金良い
どっ
ブイコレグーグル+ at なんですよ
何ストでこの配座っていうのは初速度と時間によって増加背部分の学会が生んで普通の
速度に
その後時間たして増えてゲートを足したのかそうと思ってくださっ
[音楽]
以上です
学習量性別
お待たせください
[音楽]
俺は車お使いです栄光を除く全科目終了いたしましたーーー
僕たちとこの退店してくるので配置場所待ち下さいはい
全科目120点まを入ってございます
最低は結構雨にして基本的に一番6点ぐらいが好きで参加組大雪だったら2んっ
2つ答えれってカタパペば3点わーちょっと有名な計算で行ってみましたですね
東京大学
メッセンジャーするという
前記していない
ここはい
9点通学0.3回15店リカー
23年付が描いた
me
uh
あっはぁ
400はず10点中47点でますけどでもマッハ
いや俺すごいと思いますよだって充満したら470点ですか
右側から分